στην βούλιο προσφορίς της πόλης που τα κόμαρα τι πολύς που βραπε μιανα νιάφωνή ναι
θεωρώ ότι ηλάννα κάνε προς ση σωστή κατευθύση και δείχνουν το κ ιαριθμή και δείχρνοτο
και η αντίλιψε του κόσμου σέντων κθις τουν το πράμεν ότι ηλάν να κατάτελεφταία χρόνια
έχε μια νανοδώ και στης νοικονομή κ νάπυξη και στο εγώ προσωι κάνε το εξαναπιενο
στη λάνακανακαι ηκλόφορο αλλά τελευταακριβώς αυτόθα λέάκαι θα σου λεγα ότι υπαρπαδούμε στη λευκωσία τώρα
και βρίσκω κόμε που μυλαρία κριβος πτο μου πες εσύ υμάρχε εναι πιένα μεσκάλα λάρνα
κάν και τώρα πάμε λάρνακαν ηλάρνα κα γίνι προωρισμός παρπάταμε τηλά να κατετεύριες τουρίστς τώρα
πουρπρμε κλα να κατευρίες τουρίστες βλέπείς επιχειρήσεις βλέεις επεντήσεις βλέπεις μια έτσι κινητικότητα σίγουρα ίναι
φτασίμε το σημείο που θέλουμε σε ρέχει πάρα απολλά πράματα να κάνουμε ν αλλάνα η
λάνοννα καπλών προχωρεί προστά σε ούλους τους τομιση και ως έργα τα τελευταία χρόνια εκαμε
πάνουπε εκατον εκατομύρια έργα χριματονδημένα που τα εύρωπα ικάτα μία γιατί πλογηλάρνακα ξέρει του ιδιεκτικά
ηλοποι και δεκαι εγώτε μηνίς και στο περιθόριο στον τουριστικώ τοε γαα ψέματα εξαρτάστ σε
μεγάλο βαθούμα απου τους τουρίστες γίνονται ανάπτυξης θε οι τουρίστες αγκαλιάζουνται λάνακα λέγω και λέέ
προστάτην έκθεση τις στατιστικής υπηρεσίας νομίζω ηλάν να κανεί ο νούμεροντρία προρισμός πλοετουριστές ενώ ήταν
έκτιεβδομή τα τελευταία χρόνια ότι τα τελευταία χροια έχουμε μια ναύξη σε πραγμαρικο αριμούς πάοπε
εκατοχιλιατις πουριστές με στην πολύ και οίνη τιγμή που έχουμε νίκος ίκος πνέα ξενοδοχία πυ
χτίζονται ε στην πολύ πάει μια έναν περιβάνον τραμε στη λάρνακα ότι εργοτάξει οής που
κάθε δέκαμετατα κιόνα γιρανών με στο κέντρο της πόλης είναι νέα ξενοχιακή μονάδα ή ενιγιαζόύμενα
δωμάτια ρά θέλω από ότι του τη στιγμή στη λάρνακα ν υπάρχει μια έτσι ένασου
οργασμός σε ξενοδοχία υπάρχει μια έτσι πολύ νεγάλι αύξηση στο κομμάτη που ονομάζουμε ντουρισμό και
τουριστικείμε μχανι οιος εν ο πιο αύστηρος κριτης για τον αντραδιραξι ο ποιο αυτεος κριτής
πάντα ήταν οπαβάδουμ δεν ήταν πο θε ικανοπημένος αδί πια να δικοκτό για δεν επιαςδεκανια
πια α καμιά έδναι πιας ίκοση